this week on forward a session I did at
the Aspen ideas Festival moderated by
Savannah sellers of NBC News to the
question do we need a new party this
talk got fantastic feedback and I'm
thrilled to share it all in the podcast
this week do we need a new party from
Aspen ideas festival with Savannah
sellers of NBC News
[Music]
Welcome to our program tonight does
America need a new party
I'm Kara Stein I'm a director of public
somebody thinks so I guess yeah I'm the
director of public programs at the Aspen
Institute it's my pleasure to welcome
you and our speakers tonight it's my
pleasure to introduce Andrew Yang who is
co-chair of forward party oh thank you
thank you Aspen
it's great to be back
and to discuss with Andrew we're very
pleased to have someone from our media
partner Savannah sellers anchor of NBC's
Morning News Now
hello and thank you very much for that
introduction hi everybody thank you for
being here so we can just Dive Right In
now that we've just said that thank you
for being here oh it's great to be here
with you Savannah yeah thanks for doing
this panel number eight I save the best
for last that's true you are my loss and
I am I'm always excited to talk to you
I've been fortunate enough to do that a
few times let's start we are going to
touch on a lot tonight I just want to
say that now and there will be time Mr
Yang has graciously agreed to take
questions from you as well so think of
your questions and we were definitely
going to save plenty of time to do that
at the end
um we will touch on some breaking news
that we've all seen today out of the
Supreme Court we will get to all of it
um but I want to start kind of focused
on the premise of this panel in terms of
America needing
a third party and what I have loved in
talking to you whether it is in front of
people whether it's for television or
whether it's on the phone prior to doing
one of these is how candid you are and
the last time that we spoke you said to
me very frankly after you had ran for
president you had a terrible view of
American politics and you essentially
had a bad time and you've pointed out
the fact that most Americans don't have
the chance to know what it's like to run
for president
and that you have a lot of anecdotes
about why it was so terrible I want to
start with what that time was like and
what it made what propelled you to come
out of it and think okay forward is what
I'm going to do well thanks Savannah
um I had a great time running for
president I want to make that clear uh
and grateful for all the the support
that I got on the trail I was an
unlikely candidate and I will confess to
you all I didn't actually expect to be
president
oh it's true
um
my goal was to try and prepare our
country for the most profound economic
transformation of our time uh which was
going to accelerate the displacement of
many Americans in my view the reason why
Trump became our president in 2016 we
all remember that night the reactions
you all had I had a similar reaction not
all you know most of you let's say uh
and but I thought wow what does this
mean uh and to me it was a reaction to
the fact that we'd eliminated 4 million
manufacturing jobs that were based in
Michigan Ohio Wisconsin Pennsylvania all
the midwestern swing states that Trump
needed to win and did win and my friends
in Tech knew that we were going to do
the same thing to millions of call
center workers retail workers eventually
truck drivers and Uber drivers what
percentage of Americans graduate from
college
it's about a third 35 percent or so so
when you think about the economy it's
two-thirds high school graduates and a
lot of those jobs are going to get
decimated by Ai and other things so I
ran for president to try and warn us and
prepare us for the fact that this
transition was coming and that we didn't
seem to understand it or be Reckoning
with it and our political system
certainly did not want to have that
conversation so the frustration I had
coming off the trail I met many
incredible Americans who wanted a better
future for themselves and their families
and loved it but I still knew that our
institutions were not meaningfully
grappling with the reason I ran and this
is despite the fact that I had
objectively overachieved uh you know my
wife will be the first to tell you I'd
objectively overachieved but
um but it wasn't like a mission
accomplished moment it wasn't like I did
it you know I can go home instead it was
like I still feel despondent about the
direction of American politics and our
ability to rise to the challenges of
this time
so then comes forward
and we talked a lot about how you did
this and and the nuances about
what it's like to really be doing this
across the country when I've been
talking to people their question which I
know that you have addressed before but
people may or may not know is like so is
a third party is there going to be a
third party running that they're putting
up a candidate running for the White
House is are you running that question
will be directly asked and hopefully
answered later no well my response is
apparently I have another 40 years to
run you know
let's do okay let's cut to that
um but but the great misconception about
what we're building with Ford is that
it's about the presidential because
that's what we've been conditioned to
think when you hear third party party
what do you think
Ralph Nader
Ross Perot Jill Stein perhaps and think
oh that this is meant to be a monkey
wrench into the presidential we're not
touching the presidential uh you know
we're focused on the half a million
local races here in Colorado and around
the country 70 of which are uncontested
but the Press doesn't want to talk about
that narrative the Press just wants to
go to its knee-jerk third party not
going to work despite the fact that at
this point I mean look around this room
you're all what I'd call at least a
little bit third party curious uh
but 65 of the country at this point
wants a political alternative because we
can sense that the current system is not
working and most of us are not actually
being represented so explain now what
we've talked about in terms of you
starting this as an organization across
all 50 states and that work that you're
doing if it's not about the White House
what are you doing day in and day out
who is what am I doing indeed who is
hoping
who do you want to see part take up
forward party yeah so we can talk about
it here in Colorado
um so first I want to call out my friend
Adam Frisch who's in the back row
uh now apparently a lot of you know Adam
uh yeah and Adam's running against
Lauren bobert
yes
I sense that he lost by 550 votes in the
last cycle uh the experts had him losing
by something like 50 000 so 550 is a lot
less than 50 000. and he's coming back
to finish the job so uh it's candidates
like Adam it's Jenny arndt who's the
mayor of Fort Collins who just joined
forward party uh three days ago uh we
have elected officials who are trying to
do the right thing and one of the dirty
secrets in our current political system
is that each party's not meaningfully
contesting the other party's Turf uh one
thing that Adam's too polite to say is
not like the Democrats were all gung-ho
behind him last time because they've
written off his district because it was
R plus nine and at this point the
parties are essentially Financial
allocation engines and they looked at
his district and said like that's not
worth an investment so if you look
around the country by the way that's
most of the races if you go to rural
areas it's not like the Dems are there
saying oh we're gonna make it happen and
the and the reverse is true in a lot of
the big cities not like the Republicans
are there 70 five percent of us don't
live under two-party rule we live under
one party Rule and I'm going to suggest
that that's a recipe for bad policy a
lack of accountability and a lot of
frustration
yeah
so so that is what we are trying to
change at the local level but again the
national press doesn't want to tell that
story because at this point their
business model is baked on separating us
into teams and saying you know why
you're angry and frustrated those people
over there it's not because the system
has been designed to slice us into blue
zones and red zones which by the way is
the truth of the matter the the truth of
it is that what is the approval rating
of the US Congress right now as we're
here together
I'm anchoring you low it's about 20 what
is the re-election rate for incumbent
members
94 percent
so in that system most of our votes
aren't meaningfully making a difference
because the fix is in and the reason why
that golf is so great is that 90 of the
congressional districts around the
country including where most of you live
are either quite blue or quite red
uh and so the job security of those
people in office this is the great uh
fiction in American politics the fiction
is that our leaders have to make 51 of
us happy and if they succeed in that
then they keep their job that is not
true the truth of it is that they have
to keep the 10 to 12 percent who are
voting in their party's primary off
their back to make sure they get to the
general and that's how they keep their
job a lot of the folks here know elected
representatives who seem pretty Lucid in
person but then when you get a TV camera
on them no offense Savannah they seem
like totally different people and you're
like why is that it's because their
audience is not you Their audience is
the 10 to 12 percent of the most
ideological voters in their party that
they need to keep happy so they don't
get primary that's the only way they can
lose their job well I'm here from the
national media I will just point that
out
um and I am happy to have this
conversation because I do think that
wherever the responsibility lies in
terms of getting the message out that
this is not about just the White House
and it's about local level I'm happy to
be part of that conversation tonight
yeah
um and what you've said to me prior
which I'd like if you don't mind to get
a little bit granular about is the type
of person that you are going for
there is a middle ground that is
obviously what you're going for with a
third party but the types of people in
each party that currently we are
operating within Democrats and
Republicans that you are looking for
that you do think are interested in this
well yeah so if you start a national
party it turns out you're starting 51
organizations because you have a party
in each state and then you have the
national so you look at who's showing up
and a lot of the people who are showing
up early uh are folks like Lindsey Dr
CEO who's here tonight
um so she was a professional Republican
operative who left the party when Trump
took power in 2016. and said you know
what this is not my party anymore walked
away from a lot of uh money frankly uh
to try and do the right thing for the
country there are a lot of folks
probably in this room who were
Republicans for a long time and then
have become increasingly uncomfortable
and then now you think you're
politically homeless and I'm here to
tell you that forward wants to be your
home
there are people who have felt similarly
about elements of the democratic party
where they say wait a minute uh you know
I thought the Democratic party stood for
certain things but now we seem to have
these increasingly ideological identity
based conversations that I'm not sure if
that's actually
productive or solving the nation's
problems and you can sense that the
the Crux of the energy of the party uh
is in an ideological Wing that doesn't
resemble you so folks that want to
actually have our politics reflect and
represent the people in this room but
not just the people in this room let's
just say the 70 to 80 percent of
Americans who are on the outside looking
in right now Ford wants to be your home
FAQ section of your website forward
parties you specifically reference
wanting to have this stop this voting
for the lesser of two evils yeah I do
yeah totally
um
that's what a lot of people are doing in
fact I I don't know how you would
describe when we've talked prior you've
essentially referenced who you will
likely vote for should you not be
running for the White House this year it
is more about who you're not voting for
and that's the disease we're trying to
cure with forward uh imagine imagine
this there are two people on the ballot
and you like them both so much that
you're having trouble deciding between
them
and then maybe even imagine the step
after that which is you can just rank
them one and two
and then walk away happy knowing that
one of them is going to wind up winning
that's within our reach uh all we need
to do is install ranked Choice voting or
instant runoff voting as other countries
already have done uh and then you could
have a much more representative dynamic
system where it's not just about the
lesser of two evils another friend of
mine who's here tonight is a political
scientist Lee druttman uh who's uh the
one of the foremost thinkers on this and
he said the other night which was really
funny he said you know it's not a thing
the lesser of three evils
oh
to dig into what's happening at the
presidential because it's all real
um so who are the nominees going to be
probably Donald Trump and Joe Biden
combined age 160 years old
and 65 of Americans are not excited
about those two choices they're going to
say which of these can I accept more
than the other I do also want to say
that to the extent that there is a
spoiler there's a lot of attention being
paid to something called the No Labels
Unity ticket they haven't actually
gotten to a point where that's real but
you know who is real right now Cornell
West running on the green party which
has ballot access around the country
there are people that are excited about
Cornell and like I met Cornell I get it
and as you can tell like I'm eager to
sort of have a genuine Dynamic choice
but
I will say the vast majority of
Cornell's voters are probably going to
come from one column more than the other
uh and that to the extent there is this
variable that uh that people are
concerned about like that does seem to
be the trajectory that 2024 uh is
on uh and to the extent that people are
concerned about these choices or what's
going to happen
uh
forward shares your concerns it's one
reason why we're not getting involved in
the presidential uh we're going to be
backing good pro-democracy candidates at
every level and as individuals I'm sure
we'll get involved in the presidential
in any way we can be helpful
but you know what that doesn't involve
running
yeah so you are not
again I've got 40 years but I do not see
myself running in this cycle because I'm
a math guy and the math says that if I
run I probably increase the chances of
trump winning and that is the opposite
of what I'm here to do
[Applause]
people are not excited about those
candidates
how do you feel about the two candidates
let's start with we've just name checked
well I you know I I would say that I
feel the way many of you do
um which is I wish we had better choices
uh you know the and the fact that we may
and because I think there is this lack
of enthusiasm for those two choices I
think that anyone else else who's on the
ballot is actually going to get an
outsized proportion of votes uh and I
understand that so I I think that if you
were let's say the Democratic party like
I would be having a much more robust
denomination process and if Joe Biden
emerges from that fantastic but if
voters look at Joe Biden Gretchen
Whitmer Gavin Newsom JB pritzker Phil
Murphy Roy Cooper and choose someone
else then also fantastic uh you know and
and the fact that we're not actually
having that conversation is doing the
country a disservice I think that Joe
Biden
true oh I I think that Joe Biden should
should be a Statesman and say look just
like George Washington stepped away and
said I'm going to pass this baton like
I'm going to do the same and he said
that's what he was uh going to do back
in 2020 but you know something changed
between uh then and now and this is as
someone who voted for Joe Biden
campaigned for Joe Biden spent a lot of
time with him and his family he's a
lovely man but I do not think that this
is the right approach for the country so
you would like to see him step aside
I you know if you wanted to run you
could have a genuine nomination process
you could have a genuine uh you know set
of debates for example but the the DNC
has gone another Direction and I think
that's driving a lot of frustration and
it's also on the cusp of delivering us
into a situation this is my great
frustration with the two-party system it
is uniquely susceptible to
authoritarianism it is you know like if
you look at it if you have one party
fall prey to noxious leadership all the
incentives are for everyone in that
party to fall in line
you know and so you're at the razor's
Edge just about all the time I think
that's not very smart I think that if
you were to have let's say even three
players in the system and then forward
had
you know five to ten percent in the
middle much more resistant to
authoritarianism because then if one
party goes off in its Direction they
can't control everything and then
there's also a place for folks to go and
say look I'm not down with this uh I'm
gonna head this direction it's much
harder in this binary we've set up we're
living one of the worst nightmares of
our founding fathers come to life John
Adams said two parties would be a great
evil across the land George Washington
Ward against partnership on the way out
and what are we now where the most
polarized we've been since the Civil War
and uh and the way out of this is not
doubling down on partisanship and
polarization it's trying to get us to
see ourselves as Americans country over
party and say the 8 billion the 10
billion dollars we're going to spend
beating each other up in 2024 maybe we
should spend some of that fixing the
incentives of the the system moving to
something like ranked Choice voting
moving to nonpartisan open primaries
which would actually reconnect people to
policy uh all of that and all of that is
what Ford is working on I will admit to
you all that is getting a sliver of a
sliver of a sliver of what it should be
getting relative to the eight ten
billion dollars that's going to be spent
in flaming us you'll probably get some
of that because you're a swing-ish state
so you'll you'll have the joy of the
advertisements
um but then I say to folks look we're
going to spend 10 billion dollars
beating each other up how much are we
going to spend the next day pulling us
back together
so I had planned to ask several
questions about
the president's mental competency his
age or concerns with that but it sounds
like you're telling me just that you
would like to see him step out of this
just let me put a fine point on that
yeah I think it's the right thing for
the country I do
in the wake of that anyone that you
would support
specifically
well I listed five governors uh all of
whom I think are well positioned to be
the next nominee of the democratic party
uh and I think there should be a robust
process and let the party decide
is your primary concern with the
president his age
it's definitely a real concern
um but I I think that there's something
even more
sort of Representative or emblematic of
his age what's happening so this is the
big picture Dynamic we're trapped in
that hopefully you will all help us get
out of uh you know with the forward
party
um but the Republican party has taken on
this real anti-institutional energy if
you look at what percentage of
Republicans trust the news media
uh it's 15 percent
and so if you're in the Republican party
if you run against the news media it's a
very winning strategy fake news et
cetera Etc uh the Democrats uh it's more
or less the reverse where 69 percent
have a high trust uh in in media
um and there's an anti-institutional
energy a little bit in the Democratic
party that's somewhat ideological
um so you you have Joe Biden and the
Democratic establishment uh kind of uh
getting assailed on both sides by this
anti-institutional energy
and so Joe Biden now in part because of
his age kind of embodies these creaking
unresponsive institutions and because of
that is going to engender a lot of
hostility from people who might actually
agree with him on a policy standpoint
but aren't going to be able to to get
excited about voting for them or might
not even be willing to vote for him
oh we'd always had fun together
uh uh you know
Savannah I mean you know I I actually
weigh this question all the time like am
I a positive guy or a negative guy
like I'd love to get a feel from you all
um
I mean you know I mean I'm still trying
to figure that out myself but um uh but
certainly I enjoy anytime we get to
spend together okay great just just
clearing that up
so that I hear you when you express
concern about the national media's Focus
and lack thereof on down ballot races
and simply focusing on the right Run for
the White House but when we are still
having as robust a conversation as we
are right now about the race for the
White House seeming like there is a good
chance it turns into voting for the
lesser of two evils
in that context what is your hope for
how forward party can play in the future
maybe it's election Cycles down the road
yeah
uh again there's no reason why we can't
have something like ranked Choice voting
and then if there are different people
that run then they can't spoil the
election then you can vote for them one
and then uh the Democrat or the
Republican too uh and you'd have
different factions emerge uh you'd have
again a much more dynamic system there's
nothing stopping us from doing this
other countries have already moved to
ranked Choice voting for national
elections they've seen it reduce
polarization uh it's better for women
and minority candidates by the way uh
for those of you who who
um who value uh the fact that we can
actually make our system a bit more uh
representative
um and we're not having these
conversations at all in the U.S again we
are riding this creaking infrastructure
that people are losing confidence in and
what Ford is about is trying to
modernize it so that it will stand the
test of time uh you know in in a system
that's uniquely vulnerable to
authoritarianism saying hey you know
what the plan is we're just gonna do
this even though by the way we're not
competitive and you know half the
country but we're going to do this we're
going to ride this and this is going to
actually stand the test of time I think
is a bad approach uh and we we have to
have a more honest Reckoning with what
it would take for our institutions to be
able to adapt to what what's happening
on multiple levels including uh this
crumbling confidence in how genuinely
representative our institutions are if
the president were to step aside would
you step in
it's I it's really genuinely not on my
radar uh
um
yeah it's not on my radar as you can
tell you know like I'm I'm a
professional question answer and I don't
really have a response to that uh
let's put it that way
well it's not no
uh
I know my Michael Savannah is just to
try and do as much good as I can in any
given period
um I've I've gotten so much from this
country I'm very blessed my wife is here
with us tonight I'm still married which
is the the most important blessing uh in
my life over this last number of years
because uh you know I put Evelyn in the
family through a lot over this last
number of years uh and uh I feel deeply
indebted to this country for everything
we've been given I grew up the son of
immigrants I've already had the kind of
career I could never have dreamed of as
a young person and I can tell you that
in part because my parents tried to talk
me out of running for president so it
was you know beyond the imaginations of
you know Taiwanese immigrants
that their son could try and make a
positive uh dent in our political scene
in our culture uh and I'm still just
trying to do the same thing I'm just
trying to move us in a direction that we
can all be excited about uh and my
holding office is you know is tertiary
to that if it made sense you know like I
mean I I uh Never Say Never but it's
genuinely not a focus at all
As you move forward with forward
how much will you be defining
where this party stands on issues we all
kind of know where most issues lie
between Republican and Democrat how will
you start to Define what this party
means and who for those who feel
politically homeless what this home
entails uh I sat with a new mayor elect
uh yemi mobileaid some of you might know
Colorado Springs uh and we were talking
about forward and how we could support
him and he asked hey where are you guys
in terms of uh litmus tests policies uh
those sorts of things and we said yemi
we want to support you in doing what you
think is right for your community we're
trying to empower people who can make
the best determination uh at the the
street level at ground level uh and so
our principles are fairly lofty it's
Grace intolerance election reform
um
uh actually listening to election
results you know like things that most
people would would feel pretty
comfortable with uh but then after that
in terms of the specific approach to an
issue or a problem uh we want to let the
people that know best lead in that
direction and the folks in the community
generally know best what to do
especially because communities are
different you know what works in
Colorado Springs or Fort Collins might
not be the right approach in Schenectady
so let's just
if we could take an example like let's
say a community in somewhere like
Montana where somebody where there's
quite a split it's a little bit of a
blurred line because of how somebody
might feel about gun rights but the same
way that they feel about climate change
yeah they kind of would split maybe that
like traditionally with how you would
associate that voter between parties how
do you start to put a point on what
forward is well that's exactly what our
goal Savannah uh as I was talking to
someone the other day who said look uh
what if I'm
like I I uh am pro-life but I'm also a
climate activist uh you know where do I
belong uh and what forward wants to do
is actually give rise to a genuinely
heterodox political conversation uh
that's inclusive and humanizing
um because the danger right now is that
if you disagree with me on something I'm
very very passionate about whether it's
guns or abortion or climate then you're
my enemy uh and I'm supposed to have
contempt for you
um and uh we think that that's going to
end up leading us towards this
polarization aggravation and policies
that don't resemble what people want
when when people ask me hey what
policies forward stands for forward
stands for reconnecting the people of
this country to your elected
representatives they can deliver what
you want uh and so if you were to look
and see that 75 of Americans want a
certain thing why aren't we getting it
and by the way you can do that on issue
after issue a U.S senator said this to
me and this is why what we're doing is
is so important I feel a U.S senator
said look we're at a point in American
politics where an issue is worth more to
us unaddressed than addressed
I won't address it we can get you mad we
can raise money we can get votes on it
what happens if we lean across the
island do something about it
we worked with the Enemy we're
ideologically impure we antagonized the
base our job security goes down and a
real life example of this remember Marco
Rubio proposing uh immigration reform a
number of years ago raise your hand if
you remember that
yeah what happened the next week
he just said I was kidding I was kidding
like I ever can't what happened in those
seven days
the folks in his party went to him and
said Marco what are you doing you do
this we're going to take a beating
someone's going to lose our jobs you do
nothing we're fine so you can put
immigration in that bucket but you can
also put climate in that bucket you can
put homelessness in that bucket you can
put education in that bucket you can put
democracy reform in that bucket you can
put AI in that bucket
you know like so people asked me
yesterday why aren't we making progress
on I on AI and I said the reason is that
good policy has absolutely nothing to do
with whether uh people are winning
politically uh they can do nothing as
they did on social media over the last
two decades to the detriment of our
society or democracy and our kids Mental
Health
zero political cost there is zero
political cost to them issuing bad
policy or no policy so that's why I fear
that we're going to be
uh witness to many new things that AI
engenders some of which are great but
some of which are going to be terrible
uh in large part because our government
is going to be behind the curve
transportation is the party but I have
to ask just since you brought it up and
I know because we've talked about this
and yeah I know we've got like checking
the clock no no it's actually going
really well yeah in the sense that I
feel like we're having a great
conversation covering a lot of ground
and you know I'm not like 30 seconds or
something yeah no
[Laughter]
but I just I do want to ask you since
you just said it and it's obviously if
you guys have been attending panels This
Week a huge conversation at Aspen ideas
Festival as it is with everyone AI
it's just as just briefly
what would you like to see happen in
terms of AI regulation just I mean
people look to you and yes
um there should be a dedicated Federal
agency uh that focuses solely on AI uh
there should be licenses for models that
are going to be used by more than let's
say a million people which is by the way
a very very small number because most of
these models are now being used by tens
of millions of people very quickly uh
and uh we're just all being lab rats and
guinea pigs in real time you know that
doesn't seem very smart uh I I think
there should be a cabinet secretary
secretary dedicated to this uh and then
there should be a global AI body you
can't get everyone on board but you can
definitely get the EU on board uh you
can get some people on board uh and you
start to make strides and maybe even put
some pressure on the folks who are going
to want to be outside of this global
system uh these are all steps that you
know it's not just me calling for folks
like Tristan Harris and Gary Marcus and
others are calling for them and we
should be doing these things yesterday
uh the problem is that if you go and
look at what's happening in Congress
there are a half a dozen different
proposals half a dozen different
approaches not sure which one's going to
to Prevail meanwhile these uh models are
just getting stronger and stronger every
single moment
because you mentioned Tristan who I've
spoken with a lot
um what is the worst case scenario do
you think with AI so I was with my hair
stylist who's a very positive person and
I was talking about this you can judge
her work
um but but because she's a very positive
person she said come on Andrew what's
the Worst That Could Happen uh and then
I I said to her I said well rampant
identity theft uh a total uh degradation
of public discourse and any notion of
Truth and unwarranted military conflict
including potentially nuclear conflict
and then she heard that list it was like
wow that's actually pretty bad
bad and those aren't those are
relatively predictable given where the
models are now those aren't even the
science fiction artificial general
intelligence uh like species threatening
things those are just bad actors taking
current tools and just doing things with
them that would be destructive
today you tweeted out a live blog from a
different national news organization by
the way NBC News is a great one
breaking news events uh following as we
got several Supreme Court decisions
today but of course the big news being
affirmative action uh you've spoken on
this in the past but what do you think
about what happened today it's a
reaction yeah um I think that these
racialized zero-sum games uh are not the
right conversations uh and
um this is what I wanted to put out but
because this is such like a textured
nuanced conversation I was like yeah
I'll keep it to myself but
um Harvard's endowment is 53 billion
dollars
uh they could double the endowments of
all of the top 10 hbcus next year on
interest alone if they chose to do so uh
and so if you look at these institutions
and what they're doing or not doing to
actually genuinely tackle racial
inequity uh like we're having The Wrong
conversation I mean Harvard could open a
new satellite campus in Detroit and
Memphis tomorrow it could triple its
class size and then become a more
genuine path to opportunity for more
people you know it could do a lot of
things
um but what we're doing right now is
we're saying hey here's this current
institutionalized system let's uh say
that this is the path to equity even
though by the data the vast majority of
students of color at Harvard are from
the top two socioeconomic quintiles and
probably would have been fine
you know regardless so as you can tell
this was not something for Twitter
like these are the the right
conversations and the the fact that
we're getting bogged down uh in the this
current scarcity mode uh is tearing us
apart and not bringing us together do
you essentially just think that it's not
the point
it should not be the point and my hope
is that what happened today actually
ends up galvanizing a more genuine
conversation about how we can address uh
inequities in our society
I want to Circle back to what we talked
about earlier about a growing
conversation is the age of politicians
do you think that something should be
done about that in a
yes term limits but putting caps putting
age Caps doing any type of mental
Fitness tests do you think that
age should be there should be more
parameters around it that are actually
set in stone when it comes to
politicians I remember the good old days
like the 90s maybe the 2000s
um the thought was look if you're really
really old then the voters will choose
someone else
uh but but the problem is that our our
systems have become so closed uh that
that is not happening and we're left uh
having to evaluate the mental and
physical health uh of uh people who are
you know uh past the age of 80.
um and then when people say hey the
voters can decide on something else we
can't actually you know there's actually
no way to do that so someone here in the
front uh said term limits
um and about three quarters of Americans
are four term limits uh and to me if
three quarters of Americans want
something you should probably take it
pretty seriously
um but that there are a lot of people
who are frustrated that if you get sent
to DC it does become this uh
multi-decade lifetime appointment that
that ends up uh I joke but this is
pretty accurate that DC is on a 25-year
tape delay
as a result
um and that that tape delay might be
acceptable if the pace of change wasn't
so rapid but now the pace of changes is
speeding up more and more and that tape
delay is going to become disastrous
what do you what responsibility do you
see with young people getting into
politics what would you like to see in
order to make sort of a sea change even
possible all right Savannah I know where
this is going
all right so and this is like again all
right
uh if you look at the numbers young
people are not pumped about the
two-party system or other major parties
um but they're also not that pumped
about democracy unfortunately and if you
say to them hey you got to get out and
vote you got to do these things a lot of
them uh you know tune out
um but but here's the the tough truth of
it is that in most of these environments
they actually have a point uh you know
like they've been put in situations
where again 70 of local races
uncontested on competitive 90 of the
districts are decided ahead of time in
terms of which party's going to win so
then if you go to the young person be
like hey vote vote vote they'll be like
look my vote's not going to matter and
then if you look at our system you'd be
like wow they actually might have
something there so what what we need to
do for young people is like we're going
to make your vote matter for Real uh and
then we need your help we need your help
in a very very real way
um now at the national level will you
turn out make a difference in some of
the biggest race we're talking about uh
yes it will though even in this
presidential that we're all fixated on
there are only eight states that are
going to matter you know like in 42
States if you say get out and vote they
could legitimately say to you my vote
will not make a difference and they
would not be incorrect so
so so what we want for young people I
love it when young people run uh like I
want them to run I I want them to grow
and develop
um but
I think we owe them A system that will
actually make the best use of their
talents and energies uh and we should
play it straight with them and say look
like we've left you a bit of a mess uh
you know like we're not setting you up
for success and we're gonna do our best
to fix it in an honest and genuine way
and not just put it on you and say vote
more or run more though I will say vote
more and run more
[Laughter]
what does
success look like for you with forward
party is it a number of people people
eventually come to find you is it
winning certain races
I I know there's probably many answers
to this question but give us something
tangible that you'd like to see in the
near future
a number of locally elected officials
that are forward or forward Affiliates
um over the next 12 months let's say uh
and some of you know elected officials
uh you can nudge them and say Hey you
might want to check out Ford party you
know you can join forward party and keep
your Democratic or Republican party
registration because we're not trying to
disenfranchise anyone uh you know that
the things that you have to be for are
for some of these electoral reforms and
lowering the temperature of our politics
uh saying look I can disagree with you
and and we're still both citizens and
Americans but it I think that we can get
into the hundreds in terms of locally
elected officials
um I I will say too I am a numbers guy
uh you know uh I we I'd like to see us
go from our current five to ten million
dollar budget uh up into the uh you know
triple digits
um
but I think that might be something that
happens uh in later Cycles
um but that I you know we're on that
path and I can see it very very clearly
because when we talk to Rooms like this
a lot of people are like oh wait a
minute
like this is actually like a a very
grounded gritty long-term plan that also
has short-term upside
all right how about some audience
questions you game yeah of course could
I have your uh response to whether or
not the Electoral College is a
reasonable affair way to elect a
president
um so the question was about the
Electoral College here's my proposal for
the Electoral College I hope you guys
are into it
um so there are some people that say hey
we should get rid of the Electoral
colleges go to the popular vote the
problem is you would have to get all the
rural states to vote for that it's going
to weaken their uh clown power it's a
non-starter and you would need a
constitutional amendment to get there so
what do we do
instead of saying
let's a Boston Electoral College which
in my opinion is a non-starter uh we
should say States should allocate their
electors proportionally to the
proportion of the vote that the
candidate gets in their state and one of
the virtues of this one you can get all
the states on board because you're like
wait a minute that actually helps me uh
and if you were a presidential candidate
you might go to states that are not
uh
Nevada Arizona Georgia Wisconsin
Pennsylvania uh New Hampshire right I
mean the why should the eight swing
States get all the love don't you also
want to you know see a presidential
candidate every once in a while and not
asking you for money because we're in
Aspen I know they come and ask you for
money regardless
uh so so that's a reform that would
Empower most of the states and you could
actually imagine a path to a
constitutional amendment
I saw a hand right over here
also I've got a clever way to get term
limits done
okay term limits but current lawmakers
are exempt
right and then they can just hang out
forever and be like hey look we were
formed
right it's like cost free
so Andrew I loved your book uh forward
thank you for writing it so my question
is um
about the fair use Doctrine and it's
construct contribution to polarization
in that fair use Doctrine only covers
the airwaves and not Cable in the
internet therefore there's a kind of a
race to the bottom and click bait and
and it's contributing to polarization so
how do we reverse that Trend in the
media which is driving people apart oh
thanks for the question all right
so
I'm sorry to Savannah we're going to
talk about the media again
um
uh so your political incentives that are
dragging both parties to the the
extremes because of the ideological
voters and then you have news media
separating us into teams and tribes and
then you have social media pouring
gasoline on the whole thing
uh and
one of the problems with this second
layer is that you also got rid of or
lost over 2 000 local newspapers that
used to actually be relatively up the
middle and non-partisan so after that
paper disappeared and I know an aspen I
saw you have several local papers and I
did an interview with one yesterday so
very very unusual but if you get rid of
the local paper what takes its place
cable news and social media so what
you're seeing is a nationalization of a
lot of politics uh in a way that's very
very unhealthy so what you're describing
with a fair use Doctrine uh Believe It
or Not of these three levels of
political incentives media and social
media which of those three do you think
is the most fixable
Believe It or Not by the Numbers it's
our political system uh and I'm gonna
walk you through why that is how many of
you know who Mary peltola is
if you don't have your hand up
congratulations you're not a political
junkie you're probably happier
but Mary paltola was the state
legislator in Alaska who defeated Sarah
Palin uh in the in the last cycle
um and she did that in large part
because Alaska got rid of their party
primaries in 2020.
um this is also why Lisa murkowski is
back in the U.S Senate despite being the
only Republican senator who voted to
impeach Donald Trump who was on the
ballot in 2022. by the way Alaskan
Republicans noticed this her popularity
was measured at eight percent approval
among Alaskan Republicans
so how could she actually win they got
rid of the Republican primary in 2020 so
you have Sarah Palin out Mary paltola
and Lisa murkowski back by the way of
the 10 Republican house members who
voted to impeach Trump how many of it
made it back through the primaries
two and among the eight that did not
make it Liz Cheney Adam kinzinger Peter
Meyer Anthony Gonzalez some of the
frankly the best Patriots of that cohort
but you have a system where 94 of
incumbents come back and then 80 percent
of of of of the house members of Odin
beat Trump got wiped out the only two
that made it back were in Washington
state where they had a top two primary
system and it was similar to Alaska how
much did it cost to get rid of the party
primaries in Alaska
six million dollars the best bargain you
can imagine I mean imagine if Sarah
Palin was back on our TV screens you
know we're all two IQ points dumber and
uh and like one you know one so
so
now Alaska is a cheap state in terms of
the getting rid of the primaries
um Nevada about initiative get rid of
the party primaries 17 million dollars
and at 150 347 even though both parties
came out against it
um so this is a very long way of saying
how do you get to changing fair use and
other rules is you have to amend our
political system to get better policy
the price tag in terms of mending our
politics getting rid of the the you know
the control of the extremes believe it
or not I'm going to estimate that cost
at about 200 million dollars in a system
that eight to ten billion dollars is
going to get spent beating us up and how
do I get to 200 million dollars that's
running
um
10 ballot initiatives uh in different
states with a success rate of 50 so you
might have eight ten U.S senators who
are free of their primaries and think
about how more Lucid they would be the
next day
Senators have gone up to Lisa murkowski
on the floor of the U.S Senate and said
we Envy you so much you don't have
primaries anymore
uh you know so if you get 10 Senators
who are free to do the right thing you
might save democracy and then they might
make progress on the media layer and the
social media layer Believe It or Not of
these three things I get frustrated when
people talk about oh we're going to fix
media we're gonna like fix social media
it's like you know what we're not going
to fix Media or social media unless you
fix government and believe it or not
that is actually the easiest of the
three
right here
in third row here in the Hat I have a
what basically a question like an inside
baseball question that I was hoping you
might be able to answer
um so my question is this
um
Why Won't Anyone of stature like a Gavin
Newsom or so run against Joe Biden I I
have a two-part question I mean maybe
it's a three-parter question the the
second part of the question is do you
see that also happening there being like
a credible person that does run no
offense to Bobby Kennedy Jr but somebody
of like who might actually be able to
win
um like a Gavin news or anyone of that
nature and the third part to that
question is if that doesn't happen do
you see a credible non-cornell Westie
type of person running such as yourself
and not you I know not you
um but running such as yourself as a
third party
all right uh
um what
I've heard is that the word has gone out
to Governor Newsom and Governor Whitmer
and governor pritzker and Governor
Cooper and Governor Murphy do not run
this cycle but if Joe has a health
problem between now and the convention
in August you are on the short list to
replace him
uh and so they've all been told okay
like I guess I'll uh stand down for a
minute and because they've all stood
down that the DNC can say look no
debates no process is Joe if Governor
Newsom runs then it's impossible for
them to say hey like no process
because as you say you know he's
governor of uh you know like larger
State Etc so that is what I have heard
in terms of why you're not seeing uh one
of the governors decide to step up and
challenge him despite the fact that
within those circles there are real
misgivings about uh Joe's running again
uh in terms of what have you heard there
uh I I let's just say the things that we
all think
they think too
uh and they even express them when
they're not with a reporter
um
uh in in terms of other candidates
emerging
um
I think there's a there's a real chance
of it in part because they'll look at
the numbers and say uh this is the
biggest opportunity for uh a non-major
Party candidate in a generation uh and I
like you know not going to be me and
forward but I am seeing folks who are uh
trying to game that out
um the most prominent that you would
have heard of is no labels who are at
least getting ballot access uh
potentially running
um outside of the two-party system
well I am a reporter and just said that
so let me just ask a couple follow-up
questions yeah sure
um
when you say that's what you've heard
they've been told can you elaborate on
that
uh someone who's uh who's within them uh
within the party uh said to me over
drinks in Washington DC hey this is what
uh I I I'm hearing from various people
that are close to one or another
governor
and when you say they express misgivings
anything to add there no
uh
they're having the same conversations
that many other Americans are
thank you very much
I've seen that hand in the back over
there for a while
so I love the ranked Choice voting and
everything but the restoring
Reproductive Rights was voted for in the
house and in the Senate with virtually
every Democrat that lost by two votes in
the Senate because of a republican
filibuster the same thing for voting
rights the same thing for background
checks wouldn't we better be be better
off if we just selected more Democrats
instead of having a third party
candidate
and at what level what are we talking
about no I mean for local levels I
understand but virtually every Democrat
has voted the way the American people
want in the house and the senate for a
really long time we just need a few more
because Joe manchin and Kirsten Cinema
wouldn't overcome the filibuster we can
get everything we want by electing more
Democrats in the house and the Senate
all right um so first let me say that I
agree with the general impulse that if
most Americans want something that is
the policy we should be getting and then
you have to dig in and say why are we
not getting it
um and you can look at someone like Joe
manchin and say why isn't he acting more
like Democrats want him to but the fact
is Joe manchin is from West Virginia
where Trump won by 30 points uh and uh
he's something of an anomaly there are
other Democrats who also represent
places that are not traditionally
Democratic that Joe Biden was not
competitive in and so I'm going to
suggest to you that this is a path when
you say elect more Democrats there are
whole swaths of the country that will
not elected Democrat they are not
competitive and the brand is terrible in
those places I know this in part because
I've been to a lot of those places and
when I was running for president as a
Democrat they'd say hey running for
president say yes what party Democrat
and they would go oh they'd like Flinch
like I just turned a color
um so and I don't mean the great color
that I am
oh
uh so I'm going to call your attention
to a candidate named Evan McMullen who
ran for U.S Senate in Utah against Mike
Lee Utah is a red State and a Democrat
would not win there and so what the
Democrats did is the Democrats did not
run a candidate they got behind Evan
McMullen and then he put a real race in
a place where Democrats would not have
been competitive if you put a d next to
Evan it's a non-starter if you put a d
next to candidates in rural areas it's a
non-starter so we have to think a little
bit bigger and more creatively about how
we're going to reconnect people to
leadership and by the way I'm going to
suggest the reverse is true in a place
like California where Democrats run
everything but people are frustrated
they're looking up and saying wait a
minute like well why are there drug
users uh like on this corner like why am
I considering leaving because the
quality of life is not what it should be
it's because of a lack of competition on
both sides and you're not going to be
able to deliver competition if you
insist on the blue versus red and by the
way the blue versus Reds also going to
have the byproduct of uh pitting us
against each other tearing families and
communities apart not being able to
solve problems in a lasting way because
guess what the pendulum is going to
swing back the other way so all you
would have done is stick something in
for two years that begins reversed two
or four years later that is not the path
to success
what I'll go right here and then I'll
get some on this side of the room and
we've got just a few minutes left right
here first of all congratulations for
your objectivity and honesty in all the
points that are being answering
I have a very not a very deep question
uh you mentioned twice or three times
the huge amount of money that's spent in
the presidential campaign
would it be possible for it to have a
limit of standard and then consequently
for government Governors and Senator Etc
Mayors I mean because this is lots of
money that's always thrown away
um you sound like you're from another
part of the world are you I'm an
American for 32 years but I am
originally from Brazil
I say that because people from other
countries are like wow your system you
know it's nuts in terms of money
um so so 80 plus of Americans want to
get less money in politics and like get
money out uh the path to do that is a
constitutional amendment over targeting
citizens united it's very very difficult
uh and now I'm part of an organization
called American promise that's trying to
get the Constitution amended to overturn
citizens united we're at about 10 states
it's a you know uh still many states
away
um now if you ask me the path to getting
money out of politics I'm actually going
to say to you it's forward party because
right now the the two parties if you go
to them and say hey let's get money out
of politics uh they'll say like my hands
are tied because I'm like I'm in a fire
fight with folks and like they're going
to spend hundreds of millions I'm going
to spend hundreds of millions
um so if forward manages to get in there
and uh SATA members of Congress look
don't you hate Dialing for Dollars with
60 of your time like don't you want to
spend time with your families a little
bit
you you might have a shot at uh at
engendering a real Reform movement but
it's very very hard to make that happen
from within the current two-party
Dynamic I 85 Plus of Americans want to
get uh money out of politics uh and we
should fight for it
hi thank you for for being here this
evening
I just want to follow up on something I
asked you last night
as I gave you an overview last night my
question for you this evening is
on the how
the parties that we have that represent
our country
are to say dysfunctional is is High
Praise And and often it's the way they
are in dialogue with each other which is
more like a diatribe than anything
worthy of
the human being that's standing on the
other side of
this microphone or this this this part
this place how can you do you have any
ways I don't see any
my ideal would be
Justice Antonin Scalia and Ruth Bader
Ginsburg that model they were friends
they were ideological opponents but they
were deep friends
do you think that you can bring together
people who have different ideologies to
that extent
together and honor their differences and
their Humanity in the process the
vision and goal of forward we want to be
the humanization of politics movement
and let people know it's okay to
disagree it's okay to think certain
things uh we still love you we still
value each other my co-chair at forward
is a woman named Christy Todd Whitman
who is the governor of New Jersey uh two
terms and the EPA secretary under George
W bush she's an environmentalist Christy
and I travel around the country we often
tag team various events uh I would
I would bet my life on Christy Todd
Whitman uh and we haven't actually had
policy conversations because we know
that we're unified in trying to bring
the country back together uh and that's
what so many of us want
uh so can we fight these Tides these
growing tides of darkness and
dehumanization and demonization with a
positive inclusive independent political
movement that loves our fellow Americans
that is the effort that we are embarking
on with forward and I hope we have a
chance of success
one last question from this side of the
room I'll go with this gentleman here
what do you think of the chances to rank
getting ranked voting
through
or a ranked vote oh ranked Choice voting
so ranked Choice voting was just
approved in Fort Collins it's going to
be considered in Denver uh that there
are dozens of cities that are now
considering it it just got got issued in
Oregon Statewide so if it gets approved
then every election including Federal
will be ranked Choice voting in Oregon
uh in Colorado it's been signed off on
for municipalities but not Statewide it
is sweeping the country if you imagine
even here in Colorado if Denver used it
and Fort Collins and these other cities
then it's normalized Everyone by the way
after you use ranked Choice voting
you're like oh I get it and now I love
it uh because
people have to listen to me even if my
first choice another candidate it
rewards positive campaigning because if
I trash you then we both look kind of
bad the third person uh does better if
you're a woman who's naturally a
coalition Builder you think oh like this
actually is my kind of uh environment so
there's a real wave for ranked Choice
voting around the country and if you
want to help make ranked Choice voting
happen join forward because what we're
doing is marching around the Country
Place to Place Town by town and saying
this is the way that we can take the
temperature down in our politics and
deliver Solutions uh to the American
people
Andrew Yang always a blast thank you
appreciate the out of you
big questions
[Music]